afternoon and thank you so much for
staying with us here at 4 30. i'm
christian casadas i'm kirstjen joyce
right now staffing at hospitals here in
the valley continues to be an issue
personnel they're sick or they're
isolating that's right well sally
jaramillo joins us live at sunrise
hospital with what some nurses are
sharing sally
yeah nurses terming tell me they are
extremely overwhelmed hospitals like
this one are dealing with staffing
problems and for them it feels like no
relief is on the way
it's spreading like
wildfire and the community can witness
that while nurses are helping patients
they too are needing help the nevada
hospital association reporting kova 19
hospitalizations are at the highest
since the pandemic began nurse
practitioner erica kimball explains what
she and co-workers are going through
there was a list and if you had to take
your turn on that list so if i was
already there for 12 hours and they had
no one else to come in and i was on that
list i was then staying for 16 hours
kimball says nurses and other staff are
overworked also causing stress to nurses
taking care of too many patients at once
we love our patients we want to take
care of people but we also want to be
treated fairly if you're working bedside
nursing there's a lot of pressure to be
in there you really feel like you have
to be in there even if you are like
extremely ill and hospital officials
understanding the strain in a statement
from dignity health spokesperson says
quote this is an extremely challenging
situation and we're doing everything we
can to ensure our hospitals can continue
to operate while also keeping our staff
and our patients safe dean of unlv
school of nursing angela amar agrees we
need to be planning now for how we help
to increase
the faculty increase graduate nurses
increase
our programs so that we really can meet
the needs of citizens for the future
i reached out to several other hospitals
in the valley responses were similar
that they too are dealing with staffing
problems and they're doing their best to
help out the community and of course
patience for now reporting live sally
jaramillo live local now